like a panorama in front of me
constantly I could be in a room full of
people and there was a time when I was
13 stories though I didn't I didn't talk
at all and I just just couldn't believe
it I just didn't talk and then I was
constantly talking after the war because
then I realized I was afraid if I won't
talk I'll see everything
when they took us out of her home home
room that what they did which a lot of
people left their children and carriages
hoping somebody will take them but
nobody did so they knew they were Jewish
children they're just grabbing just
threw them on the trucks or though
people just threw them and cripples they
just straight in front of us just in the
head
just shut in there just that part of the
world no human beings so those things
that just stay with you this is
something you don't forget so you see
the trucks you see very babies you see
screaming mothers you see changing
people the sick and every time you see
that face there I was working in town we
were gathering wood and they had to
supply a horse and wagon to drag the
wood to the German police department I
see a man of a farmer
his name was mythic tall farmer of mas
de jure a redhead mustache turn he used
to be one of our better customers so he
recognized me I used to bring his shoes
deliver his shoes with my father and
used to let me into the field before the
war pick strawberries
the attack was like a friend of the
family you know he was a good customer
but also like like a nice person so he
told me he pulled me away on the side
and he told me that what the eyes have
seeing when they evacuated the people
are woman tore their heads out you know
it was was a one day in early fall was a
warm day I remembered the Sun was
shining everything but not for Jews so
he told me
and later we found out we found out we
didn't want to believe that such a thing
is possible what did you tell you the
the the tragic March 15 kilometers from
rolling to gah robotica where was a
train station and how they packed them
in because he had to stay there until
everything is all the cattle cars are
sealed but they can go home and I myself
have experienced evacuation from
scourges to boot about when the Russian
front came here we went trains for a few
days we couldn't go out couldn't relieve
ourselves so I must end then and after
the war you read they all read some
books how its described and everything
else is history and I remember we were
laying come to here and the barracks
there no parents alone cold hungry how
my brother was always praying
so sometimes reason he became religious
and started to play
he places he shouldn't be killed for a
bullet
so he became sick and they took him to
the hospital it didn't give him any
medication and one night I came up there
and I myself was sick before typhus and
he had typhus fever
I knew the feeling from experience and
he was laying in bed and said it gave me
the jacket the blue jacket
and they took him out they clean up the
hospital and they took him out to virtue
and scars condition I had their baby boy
and I didn't have food for the baby so I
took out I took milk from my breasts and
my soul to other mothers for pc so
potato and I didn't have where to put
the babies over here the chair and we
cut off one leg of the chair in order to
rock the baby which I should Rock so we
put the baby the energy and while I was
taking milk I was getting lumps in my
breasts when I went to the doctor and
she said that I have passed in my breast
because I didn't have the proper food
and I started to have pain and she said
we have to operate so I had to go there
by myself and I went through operated
with no injection they took us with the
buses they brought us to a big airfield
and nearby were trains the cattle trains
and as I look back at I think it for a
while I was in a daze I didn't know what
was happening actually I saw they taking
away the men separate the children
separate and the woman separate so I had
had the baby
I took the codes for the head with the
bundles and I wrapped around the baby
and I put it on on my left side because
I showed the Germans were saying left or
right
and I went through with the baby but the
baby was short of breath started to
Chuck to choke and it started to cry so
the German called me back
this is what do you have there in German
now I didn't know what to do because
everything was so fast and everything
happened so suddenly I wasn't prepared
for it to look back the experience was I
think I was numb or something happened
to me I don't know but it wasn't I
wasn't there I even and he stretched out
his arms I should hand him over to the
bundle and I hand him over the bundle
and this was the last time I hid the
bundle but I look back I don't think
that I had anybody with me I was alone
within myself
and since that time I think all my life
has been alone even when I met Jack I
didn't tell Jack my past Jake just found
out recently I think to me I was dead I
died and I didn't want to hear nothing
not anyone and no nothing and I didn't
want to talk about it and I didn't want
to admit to myself that this happened to
me and I still have I found the doctor
who operated on me in the ghetto and
they brought us in there and when she
told me that she was so happy to see me
right away she said what did what
happens the baby what happened to debate
and right there I said what baby I said
to the doctor but baby I didn't have a
baby
I don't know of any baby that's what it
did to me that doesn't seem possible the
10 years have passed since you were
originally interviewed I wonder if you
can remember back 10 years ago of that
interview experience itself what comes
to mind well it was scary because this
is the time we started to speak about
our incidents what happened to us up
till that till then we always suppress
things oh I don't know we didn't want to
talk about it maybe nobody wanted to
listen maybe because we just didn't feel
like talking about it because it was
painful and it took me quite a while to
come down from that interview ever soon
then you get something where you just
can't pull it out of your mind
and this is when I got older the more
the older I get the more I think of that
particular person people did get married
in the ghetto people think that together
was just you know close and they were
getting married because people had hope
things will go on and there was that my
mother's a friend's daughter she was 18
years old
Rachel Goldfarb you have to mention
names they're not here she got married
me she got pregnant
became pregnant and when we had the when
they took us out of the city we didn't
have a train there was no trains to walk
to the trains which was some I don't
know six kilometer 12 I don't know that
my largest cigar backed up and I always
remember Rachel that the record should
have very big stomach I mean I was 11
and a half bars close to 12 so at the
time I didn't you know you don't think
about things like this she was pregnant
and she was very big it was very hot
that was the second thing of suckers
they happen to be very hot and she was
wearing a trench coat and her father's
shoes that's something I can't forget it
and my mother her mother her father and
some other when we were looking around I
made a circle around her because I don't
know either she would deliver the baby
soon or they didn't once they assess to
see her I don't know
and she never complained I've asked for
water or anything years the nurse later
well I had my own children of her son
she came to mine I mean all that time it
was just like everything else but when I
became pregnant of her son of Rachel's
face was always in front of me what
happened to her the older you get the
more I try to put this here frustrating
and and how defying fascination that
people let this happen there's a bunch
of people marching old people are shot
crippled people are shot and there again
not too many people who lived through
that particular time winner or epic will
you march to the trains and we still
talked about it you're not on the train
I mean if I'm still here
I mean they walked us to the trains and
we smelled the chlorine or whatever
they're on the train to smell it because
we were sitting here and the trains were
just a little farther up how do you
forget this year I mean you said with
your mother you said with little cousins
and the beautiful babies uncles and
people you know and you know what
happened I mean you know they went to
those trains and they probably choked to
death in those changes get things the
war began
and we wore Jewish stars and I remember
my mother telling me that this is
something that should make me very proud
because because Jews were very special
it's sort of my first awareness of being
a Jew and then they began to take the
deportations began from Slovakia now
what happened then I remember very
clearly there was a priest in Rome in a
Greek Orthodox priest and the law a law
was passed that anybody who had
converted to Christianity before 1938
would be exempt from being deported he
agreed to put on the list of people who
had been converted any Jew who wanted to
be there to fake the list but he
insisted that the children be fully
baptized legally converted to Greek
orthodoxy and so my parents chose to do
that and I was converted to be a
Christian I was I remember the holy
water be poured over my head and from
that time I have a vision
it was either a dream or a vision I'm
not sure which but it the whole image is
very clear in my mind this is the image
I am on a meadow and there are Jewish
kids playing around me and at one point
they move away from me and I'm alone on
this meadow and God appears before me
and he's a mountain and God holds in his
hand an axe and it just goes
takes the ax over his head and with a
full swing splits me in half into two to
do in question I think it's more like
killing me by punishment it doesn't feel
like chewing Christian it feels like the
annihilation I have like little
vignettes and and they keep coming back
and more things keep coming back as I
write I said oh my goodness I couldn't
even remember that I couldn't I couldn't
remember that night even when I
celebrated my birthday in when I was
hiding out and my father wanted to do
something he asked me what would you
like for your birthday and I said two
scrambled eggs and I said how we gonna
get two scrambled eggs from the peasant
we obviously have to bribe him and we
looked around in all our possessions and
I noticed him staring at me and staring
at me and I couldn't figure out what he
was staring and finally I saw it and I
picked up to my ears you know and I and
he nodded so I took off my two Golden
Ears and gave it to him and he gave it
to the peasant and within a few hours I
had two scrambled eggs and I saw a
father the happiest father in the world
when he watched me the only thing yes I
I couldn't really enjoy it because there
were all these people around me watching
me eat those two scrambled eggs and to
this day I still keep dreaming about all
these people watching me eating those
two scrambled eggs well I tried to find
a people who had in me
it was sorry
well maybe it was very difficult and as
we were driving down down that Street I
recognized the house side was very
strange because I didn't know we were on
the street it's amazing not only that
but as I ran to the house
the name was on the door about the same
thing although different people are
living there no but they're related so
they have kept a name it turns out that
granddaughter divorced them to back her
maiden name I don't quite understand I
don't know of course the granddaughter
but the name was on the doorbell so it
was it was it seemed incredible that
after all these years of of this sort of
not remembering and hiding to just go to
a door and have been ringing a doorbell
to have the name I think one of one of
the most difficult things about the
whole experience had been partly the
lack of memory and feeling that as
though it never happened it was not true
and feeling quite lost and and I think
there were images which became very
strong and that I may have fastened on
and hung on to and by now they're gone I
mean by not all that is gone it's really
as other waters have closed my first
memory the horror of depredation was
this we were warned that there would be
a deprecation the least thing these
depredations came in waves and if you
somehow I'm not clear on how it was
legally but if you survived it then you
were safe for a while again it was there
were some quotas that were to be met and
we went into hiding and I remember we
were in an attic of a Gentile friend of
the family and I saw through a little
crack in the window Jews being herded
towards the railroad station
and and this was over we went out we
came down again and all the other Jew
somehow came back that were not deported
and we were there were some children of
us and we went looking to to the houses
that people were deported reported from
and we went to the house of the short
cut the short hit from home in a we live
in a very small house the window was so
low to the ground that even as a small
child I was able to look through it and
inside there was nothing but rubble
everything was broken up and all over
the floor there were his little books
that he used to tear off tickets from to
give you as a receipt for the chickens
that you took to him to kill someone who
blew some red green and oh I remember
all I wanted to do was just get one of
these books for myself they looked very
desirable and then I crawled in through
the window I took some of the books and
somehow then I realized that this man
was taken away two years ago when I was
down in the chasm the feeling that
overwhelmed me was that there were
people
who only lived in my memory and I was
the only link to the world for these for
the people the shortcut of whom anyway
and the feeling was just so awful but
what I did was I called him my son I was
still in bed then and I said what I want
you to do is hear about the shortcut of
whom in it so that you will also
remember him and I told him about the
shortcut at home in it and my son said
to me okay I will remember you and I
know he will
you